it's my birthday and Mama sharp here has
some secrets that I really wish someone
had shared with me sooner probably would have
saved me a lot in therapy right pops [Music]
yeah super quick jump in here I need to tell you
about my sponsor today element so you guys have
heard me talk about element for a while now but
it's a product I was using well before I started
start working with them and I obviously still love
it today it was great when I was breastfeeding
essential for when I play tennis in the Heat and
it helps with keeping my electrolytes balance that
some of my medications tend to throw off a lot
of my colleagues in Sports Nutrition also swear
by element specifically because it has a science
backed electrolyte ratio of 1,000 Mig sodium 200
Mig potassium and 60 Mig magnesium and it has
no colors sugar or fillers I'm still a fan of
the mango chili it's always been my fav I
love the heat but they have nine different
flavors and they are nail launching their element
chocolate medley for the cool weather months ahead
so there's chocolate raspberry chocolate mint
and chocolate chai which I'm sure is going to
come in handy for ski season up here in Canada
the medley is only available for a limited time
only so if you love The Salty sweet chocolate
flavors you're going to want to stock up right
now element is offering my viewers a free sample
pack with any order so that's eight single serving
packets for free with any element order this is
a really great way to try all eight flavors or
share element with a salty friend so get yours
at drink element.com slabby and again this deal
is only available through my link so you've got
to go to d r i n KLM nt.com slabby sharp to get
yours but anyways is your birthday girl Abby sharp
welcome back to my channel I'm going to be taking
a little slower today I got my coffee I got my
protein shake I got Poppy's cheese her reward
for not barking throughout this because yeah it's
my birthday I'm an adult and I can do what I want
right yeah poppy loves that but I am officially 36
years old today which honestly feels like such an
anticlimactic age last year I had a big party
for 35 and I stayed in a hotel and I did like
a whole overnight thing with my friends and no
kids and I love that cuz I've always been like
a really big birthday girl but no I'm keeping
it relatively lowkey this year even though I
also kind of feel like I have more to celebrate
now than ever before but you know at 36 I really
do think that I'm probably at the best place
in my life this has been a really good year
for me and I don't necessarily mean MoneyWise or
career-wise even though there's a lot of really
exciting things in the works but I just feel like
I'm really at peace with myself now my mind my
body my spirituality everything just kind of seems
like it's finally falling into place I am double
fisting it this morning with the Beverages and
I love that for us I love it for us bow down to
percules but yeah I just really wanted to share
some secrets that I feel like I've cracked the
code on that helped me get this place that I
only wish I had some insight into decades ago
so breakthrough number one poppy NOS this I know
this we both know this has really been medicating
for my mental health honestly this has probably
been one of the most important action items that I
have taken for my health that's literally impacted
every area of my life you know I really resisted
psych medication for so long despite suffering
from crippling insomnia I had an anxiety disorder
ocpd and as I recently learned also ADHD which was
undiagnosed for most of my life and it would have
been nice to know that like a decade ago but as
I discussed in my video here about pill shaming
you know I was really scared to go on medication
because of the stigma there's just such a toxic
narrative in the Wellness Community that food is
medicine and if you take it any drugs you're like
taking the easy way out you're cheating you're
not trying hard enough and I have never taken the
easy way out of anything like so I just feel like
hard work and struggle has just been the song I've
always sang but taking medication for my sleep
and anxiety has literally changed every aspect
of my life you know sleeping better has helped
improve my tolerance for stressful situations
it's improved my marriage and other relationships
it's helped me be a more compassionate and kind
parent Maybe way more efficient at my job it's
helped improve my immune system and gut health
and help manage cravings and even my set point
weight Etc dit for anxiety Mets there is no
aspect of my overall health picture that hasn't in
some way been improved by these drugs honestly had
somebody told me when I was 20 that it's okay to
take a bill to quiet the obsessive thoughts in my
brain I am quite literally 100% confident that
I wouldn't have spent a decade clawing my way
out of a a full-blown eating disorder and the
years of self-loathing that followed and this
is why I talk about my mental health Journey you
know I'm really trying to destigmatized in hopes
that it encourages others to seek the help that
they need better or earlier than I did I just
feel like I wasted so much of my important
life now the second really big breakthrough
for me has been making peace with not having a
perfect diet my 20s were no doubt my worst era
emotionally and physically and a lot of that was
due to my struggle with orthorexia you know I am
admittedly a perfectionist as I discussed in a
lot more detail in my video here and I spent way
too much of my time in the past obsessing over
diet Perfection you know meeting specific grams
of protein or specific amounts of fiber Omega-3s
or specific calories or numbers portions Etc and
when it end up happening to me and actually
happens to a lot of people with disordered
eating or EDS like orthorexia it literally just
became too uous for me to count up calories and
nutrients in every meal or different meals every
day so I basically just ended up eating the exact
same breakfast lunch dinner snacks every single
day without any sort of variation whatsoever I
became terrified of changing things up same fruit
same cheese same chicken couldn't even change a
brand God forbid an instaart Shopper couldn't find
what I ordered and maybe this also had to do a
little bit with the undiagnosed ADHD but there was
obviously also that orthorexia opponent as well
and there was nothing intuitive about this like
the only joy that I would derive from food was
during a massive binge after eating chicken and
broccoli twice a day 7 days a week so it's like
i' be dragging myself through salmon three times
a week to meet my Omega-3s and I never sto to ask
myself if I even like salmon what did you say I
said I don't want to any damn salmon cuz I didn't
really but what I've learned over the past decade
is our diet does not need to be perfect to thrive
it definitely doesn't need to be perfect every
day our bodies are so incredibly resilient and
if we're getting a variety of different proteins
and fats and Grains fruits and veggies over time
along with of course enough calories we are very
likely meeting at least most of our nutrient needs
and when we don't just because you know we've got
preferences or restrictions Etc supplements can
be a really great stand in so like I do my protein
shake most days a week because I don't always feel
like cooking protein especially in the morning or
even for lunch sometimes if I'm super busy and I
take certain key vitamins like Omega-3s every day
because like I said I don't want to eat salmon or
trout all the time not my favorite and you know
as a dietitian of course we are supposed to be
pushing for a food first approach to nutrition and
I just guessed that early on in my career I took
that Mantra way too conservatively but I've been
doing this for a really long time now and I've
since learned that a carefully planned supplement
Reg can really help to take the pressure off of
needing that perfect diet which just opens the
door for food freedom and just having a better
more relaxed relationship with food so yeah once
I better understood what foods I like or don't
like or feel good to me or don't feel good to me
as someone with IBS for example of course also
getting regular blood work and working with my own
dietitian I've been able to better understand a
supplement regimen that works for me which has
done wonders for my relationship with food as
well and speaking of of eating and you know what
feels good that is another huge 30-some learning
for me you know I feel like I have finally learn
how to respect my body which in my 20s I would
not have even been able to touch not only did I
hate my body in my 20s and by association hate
myself every single time I caught a glimpse of my
body but I had zero regard for its needs and what
felt good it's like I just wanted to punish it in
every way imaginable at both extremes I was either
eating an entire pizza and a whole order of wings
and an ice cream sundae to the point of sickness
or I was starving myself on just like a bowl of
steamed vegetables nothing about my relationship
with my body in my 20s was respectful and I'm not
saying that we should expect 20s something year
olds to eat like 30s something year olds the
kids can rally a lot better than us they got
faster metabolisms they got faster recovery from
like less healthy behaviors Etc but I just wish
I had learned to respect my body not love it not
love it not think I look snatched 24/7 but respect
its basic Primal needs like just respecting that
it felt better to eat an actual sandwich than a
salad with no dressing or respecting that it felt
better to have dinner before a night out drinking
than to try to save calories for more shots or
respecting that it felt better to have regular
balanced meals throughout the week rather than to
starve ones for 6 days only to have a big binge
that's a respect issue to me that's not like an
age thing and I definitely feel like I could have
figured that out way earlier on in life had I not
been restricting now at 36 years old I respect my
body enough to pay attention to how different
foods make it feel and if I do avoid something
I don't feel deprived because it's from an act
of self-care so like I don't feel a huge desire
to eat a big piece of cake with ice cream and like
three sugary cocktails on a Tuesday night because
I know that physically it's going to give me the
I and I also know that if I don't have vegetables
at dinner I'm not going to feel great the next
day things aren't going to be moving so well
down there this is data that I've collected so I
now can intuitively make more nutritious choices
without there being this sense of restriction and
rebound binge because ultimately I respect my body
and I really really wish I had figured this
out in my 20s poppy you are drooling all over
me going to have to wash these jeans we of to talk
about exercise I have just stopped doing exercise
that I hate and it is liberating you know in
my 20s I had I guess a lot more free time on
my hands because I didn't have kids I didn't have
a mortgage I didn't have dog I didn't really have
any major responsibilities outside of myself and
the result is that I had set up this expectation
where I would drag myself through a lot of
strenuous exercise that I legitimately hated
I [__] hated it I would spin several times
a week plus do some kind of strength training
Fitness class I mean there was no question I had
an ere exercising problem that was part of the Ed
but it really really really made me hate exercise
for a while because it just didn't feel good for
my body right like my body was fully depleted but
these days I've Got a Way healthier relationship
with movement where I've literally just given up
anything and everything that I don't like been
inning bye running definitely bye cuz there's no
way I'm dragging myself through a brisk walk when
there's a 99.9% chance I'm going to pee my pants
e your pants is cool consider me Miles Davis but
yeah I've just tried to ReDiscover all the things
about movement that I love and I just refuse to
drag myself through if I don't so typically this
means I walk every day either outside if I can
especially cuz I've got a dog so it definitely
encouraged me to do so or inside if it's not
so great I work with a trainer a few times a
week that I love and I just started taking up
tennis about a year ago which is great cardio
and also super duper fun and I cannot wait to
play with my boys one day cuz they're loving it
too it's like a family thing for us now but yeah
not only is this amazing for my mental health but
I'm actually in much better physical shape now at
36 after two kids then I was in my 20s pre IVF in
pregnancy so despite what 20-some Abby feared not
burning a of calories through exercise didn't
suddenly make me gain a of weight or become
unhealthy that I wish I knew right and finally
and this is probably the most important right
here right now I have stopped living for other
people's approval you know struggling with your
self identity and self-confidence is kind of par
for the course in your 20s but I feel like a lot
of my struggle had has been related to being told
that I was different or difficult you know there's
lots of labels that people have used to describe
people like me anxious too sensitive unstable
weird perfectionist Gladiator temperament highly
sensitive person Orchid neurod Divergent gifted
Etc and in my childhood and teens and even young
adulthood most of the labels use specifically for
me to me have been the ones with the more
negative connotation so it's like I don't
get you so therefore you must be crazy but this is
partially why the ADHD diagnosis was so incredibly
freeing for me I finally felt like I understood
my brain like I understood that it could be used
in unique extraordinary ways and I finally could
look back on all those years of being told that
I was wrong with compassion rather than just
more self-loathing and shame it truly opened
the doors for me to do do great things I can see
it in my work I can see it in my mothering I can
see it in my marriage and I can definitely see
it in my physical and emotional health it's like
the rigidity in me that has held me back for so
many decades three decades has softened because
I don't have to be so guarded I can put the cards
on the table and I can say proudly that this is
who I am and I love who I am and this confidence
means I'm not overanalyzing every interaction
reaction or going down the shame spiral every
single time a troll says I'm stupid or I'm fat
or I'm ugly or something insu like oh I used to
like Abby Shar but now I find her annoying and
that doesn't mean I'm cocky and it doesn't mean
that I'm not open to being wrong or changing the
way I do things based on feedback you guys know
I've always been very very open to your feedback
but it means that it took literally 36 years to
know my worth and to love myself even through
these imperfections and little quirks and of of
course some of this self-actualization has just
come with age I wouldn't expect 20-year-old me to
be this wise but I know I would have suffered a
lot less working in such a public facing industry
had I done more psychological and spiritual work
upfront and that's asking a lot of 20-year-old
Millennial me but I hope that the work that us
Millennials and gen Z's have done will benefit
our kids Generations so that maybe by the time
that they're getting to their 20s they're already
a lot more self-secure you know a lot of people
ask me what my goals are for my kids and I think
that they expect me to say something about them
oh I just want them to be healthy and go to
Harvard or Oxford or meet a nice partner and
have a family or carry on the family business Etc
but it kind of just throws them off a little bit
when I literally just say I want them to love who
they are all their little weird annoying quirks
and all because it's that strong sense of self
and self-confidence and self-worth that I believe
will bring in all those other external markers
of success I honestly think 36 is going to be
one of the biggest and best years of my life so
I am very excited to take it all in and on that
note I'm going to finish my shake CB's going
to probably finish this cheese and have a lot
of diarrhea and we're going to watch a Little
Love is Blind but I know a lot of New Year's
resolutions are coming up so I hope this gives
you a little inspiration for some things to work
on that doesn't revolve around calorie restriction
but I hope you guys enjoyed this video definitely
leave me a comment below give it a thumbs up don't
forget to subscribe and hit up my description for
my three hunger crushing combo ebook and
I will see you next time on aby's kitchen
bye